do we look okay do we look okay with my
eyebrows Oscar how can your business be
extraordinary we're going to answer that
question in today's episode of lunch and
earn so I recently sent out an email to
my newsletter list about this
extraordinary entrepreneur that I know
they mark Draeger who built a
million-dollar business by being
extraordinary and I got a question back
from one of my readers love you guys
brought in to say thanks a lot for this
motivation I want to be extraordinary in
child protection as my specialization
how can I go about it so I thought the
best way to answer it was to bring on
mr. extraordinary himself and shed some
wisdom what do you think I think it all
depends on whether you identify with the
word or not you know it for me
extraordinary is a really personal thing
that's the word that that for years I've
identified with and when we had a
conversation like for 34 years ago on
the phone I kind of confessed to you
with like almost a little bit not not
ashamed but almost a little bit scared
to say it out loud that I really wanted
to be an extraordinary father I wanted
to have an extraordinary business I
wanted to be an extraordinary Christian
and and husband to my wife and so for me
you know I was almost afraid to share
with Evan that I wanted to be
extraordinary if you want to be
extraordinary and that's who you are and
that's the word you identify with then
the first thing to do is just to start
being yourself it doesn't matter the
industry it doesn't matter your role
within a company if you're happen to be
working for someone else or working on
your own the best thing about about
working with that word that you identify
with is it helps you be a pure version
of yourself the best advice I can give
is if you want to be extraordinary it's
something to achieve to it's something
to work towards it's something you
identify with and help you make
decisions with more than anything else
so I would just say start living it
start living it and and I can identify
that word and run with it what I would
add is I would just kind of see the
world through that lens of
extraordinaire and just always ask
yourself is this extraordinary right
like we can't tell you I don't know what
your business is about child protection
services or whatever it was it doesn't
really matter it's asking yourself and
you've been the benchmark for success
as to doesn't meet your criteria right
like is your website extraordinary in
your eyes is the way you deal with
customers extraordinary in your eyes is
you know your routine in the morning
extraordinary in your eyes and by
constantly asking yourself that question
it'll gradually become extraordinary
that really is who you are in the one
word that resonates most with you I
would also say trickling down on the
operation side I mean if you really want
an extraordinary business whatever word
you identify with it comes into the
staff you have the procedures you have
the way you handle clients as Evan said
the type of projects you choose to take
on or not the type of work you choose to
do or choose not to do the greatest
thing about picking that word and
working towards being extraordinary as
it brings everything into focus it helps
you turn away the stuff that might take
you off the path it helps you focus on
the path you should be working towards
so thanks for the question the question
that we have for you guys today is if
you have worked through the process of
identifying a word you connect with what
is that word and do you agree with me do
you find that it helps bring things into
focus what does this open up for you
leaving the comments below will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon